welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the Scarlet Witch's massacre in
Doctor Strange of the Multiverse Madness
was nearly even more vicious according
to a rejected version of Wanda's assault
on the sorcerers at kamertage shared by
the film's fight coordinator Liang Yang
now this footage is what is called a
stunt previz in which the stunt team is
given a script or a plot breakdown early
in production of pre-production and they
use that to choreograph a version of a
fight sequence and then they edit it
together with bfx and music in a
previous or a pre-visualization to help
the director conceive how it could look
in the final film and I think we need to
explore this area of MCU filmmaking a
lot more because it is such a huge part
of the way Marvel Studios assembles its
biggest moments these stunt teams are
not given enough credit for crafting in
many cases from scratch what fans will
later appreciate as the most iconic
visuals the images that the studio will
sanctify in future Marvel Studios title
cards or other marketing Fanfare and
while this Wanda stunt sequence didn't
appear as is the Multiverse of Madness
theatrical cut its DNA totally inspired
other parts of the film in ways that you
might not realize so Liang Yang was the
fight coordinator for Dr Strange in the
diverse Madness but is also the stunt
coordinator for the upcoming film the
Marvels and as someone who's lucky to
see the d23 trailer footage for the
Marvels the fight choreography of Kamala
Monica and Carol working together looks
so good so this footage is what's called
a Warner it's one unbroken shot and it's
picks Wanda the moment she would have
landed in the commentash courtyard here
she levitates a few Sorcerers and throws
them to the ground then she enchants the
katana of one of the sorcerers notice
she doesn't enchant the sorcerer himself
as he continues to react to all of this
and then uses that blade to fight off
two other sorcerers cutting through one
of them and then trigger warning he
brings that blade to his own neck all
the way around it so that you know he
drops out of frame and then she
levitates his decapitated corpse and
uses it to continue fighting two others
and we just gotta pause here to show
some love for the understanding the
shows of Wanda's sorcery and the limits
of her power when she's fighting other
sorcerers she cannot completely take
possession of their conscious bodies and
Spirits which makes sense because they
are trained Sorcerers who were just
commanded to fortify their minds by
their sorcerer Supreme and fighting a
sorcerer's Soul requires a whole other
level of combat in the astral plane but
Wanda can puppet their weapons and their
corpses once their souls imparted from
their bodies so then Wanda Dodges the
blow and then uses her sorcery to stop a
staff and then again controlling the
weapon not the person redirects that bow
into the other sorcerer then she twists
that guy's neck and then enchants
another sword to take down another guy
and then grabs that guy by the head and
off screen gives him the Black Bolt
treatment and then she no look grabs the
final combatant and then you can see the
stunt team wired this guy so they could
suspend him in air and then another
trigger warning here she boxes in his
limbs until his whole body just explodes
and you can totally see how this
inspired the way Wanda suspended and
unraveled Reed Richard's body until she
reached his head and just popped it like
a pinata it's also similar to the
gruesome move from another Marvel Omega
Level mutant David holler from fx's
Legion season 2 episode 6 when he kills
the cop
thank you
now if you watch the fantasy you start
getting real obsessed with Bloodlines do
you want to lay a claim to a kingdom
having the right lineage is key for most
of us our actual real life Bloodlines
have nothing to do with royalty but you
can fill that Gap in your heritage by
making your own bloodline in bloodline a
free mobile game on IOS and Android
bloodline takes place in an awesome
fantasy world with amazing Graphics
you'll choose Champions find Companions
and raise powerful Offspring you can
customize your Champions by marrying
different Bloodlines and building out
your family tree until you find the
perfect combo of abilities to suit your
gameplay style the Bloodlines are so
cool there are the werewolf assassin
likeness the dragonborns of carg who can
naturally turn into real dragons in the
demigods of fulgar my favorite since
they have the best area of effect skills
and I like letting everybody know how
badass I am if you can't wait to start
making a unique lineage of your own then
download bloodline by using my link or
scanning the QR code and you'll get a
super rare half Dragonborn half demigod
hybrid error for free you'll also get an
exclusive starter pack worth 20 that has
100 000 gold 20 into intimacy packs and
100 diamonds just scan the QR code or
click the link in the description to get
started with bloodline really the more
you dig into this whole world of stunt
previous reels the more you realize how
much of the best MCU moments came
directly from these stunt coordinators
like you can find a similar sequence put
together by Thomas Robinson Harper and
Chris Cornell for Captain America the
Winter Soldier with Bucky and Kat played
by James Young and Sam Hargrave now of
course Sam Hargrave went on to serve as
Chris Evans stunt double and a stunt
coordinator for civil war Infinity war
and end game and actually he and his
brother Daniel hardgrave did the stunts
for the cap vs cap fight in in game in
fact win cap salutes America's ass
that's a Hargrave ass and then the Russo
Brothers teamed up with Sam Hargrave and
Chris Hemsworth for Sam hargrave's
directorial debut and extraction and his
upcoming sequel extraction 2. this is
actually becoming more and more of a
thing where these stunt coordinators are
so good at what they do they're actually
letting them direct big movies David
Leech Direct to Deadpool 2 was the stunt
coronary worked on the John Wick films
because it requires that much
understanding of action and where to put
the camera and how to concede these big
moments that is a big part of directing
these movies overall another Pro in the
stunt industry is Dave McCumber who did
stunts for Infinity war and game and the
fact of the Winter Soldier he has
definitely been one of the guys turning
this whole process of stunt previous
into fully realized sales pitches with
fun editing the effects music and
intensity and the performances from the
stunt actors McComb we're actually Cameo
to in in-game as one of the sorcerers
and you can see it in the reels that
McCumber has released how his team
choreographed Thor's arrival in Infinity
war with Groot and Rocket and a lot of
the stuff in the wizard duel with ebony
mob a lot of the best visuals from the
Falcon the winter soldier from the blood
on the Captain America shield to the two
on one fight in the penultimate episode
when John Walker nearly rips off Sam's
falcon wings and how Sam and Bucky use
Johnny mayonnaise as a bat to Ram him
into the shield and Kom to the uses of
Henry Jackman's score from Civil War
[Music]
all these things had their roots in a
cumber stunt read this sequence and some
of the best things we saw in endgame
including cap wallowing Thanos with the
combined attacks from mjolnir and the
shield were all part of the stunt previz
as well so getting back to Liang Yang's
brutal fight choreography for Wanda and
Multiverse Madness there were reports of
deleted sequences that would have
involved more decapitation elements like
we know the original opening scene would
have shown Wanda be Hedy mordo and last
month the Storybird artist even
confirmed Wanda showing up at cumbertage
with mordo's head and I definitely
remember there being reports of Wanda
puppy in a decapitated sorcerer at
kermitage that was shot by Sam Raimi for
this movie ultimately the brutality of
the sequence resulted in the imagery of
Wanda slaughtering the Illuminati being
as violent as it was and I for one am
very grateful for that like she does
cave in a bleeding Ultron Sentry head
and she uses her combatant's own weapons
like Peggy Carter's Shield against them
and as we all hope for the announcement
of a Scarlet Witch solo title this Brave
is reel definitely makes an excellent
proof of concept from what can still be
done with his this character so what are
your hopes for a Scarlet Witch solo film
you can follow me on Tick Tock Instagram
and Twitter at avos Poland rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]